this video is sponsored by the language
learning app babel use the link in the
description to receive up to 65 off your
subscription
nova was seven years old when he found
out he had cancer
acute lymphosodic leukemia
although he was still too young to fully
realize what this meant he knew by the
faces of his mother and father that this
was indeed very bad news
over the following years nova went
through the phases of chemotherapy and
the processes of treatment he was a
strong and resolute child but
understandably he still often wondered
to himself why he was so unlucky
why was i given cancer
why me
he would ask himself
for years nova went through the physical
and emotional pains of fighting against
the cells in his own blood and bone
marrow
when he was 12 years old he won the
fight
he was fully in remission
although physically healthy he remained
forever infected by the experience
he had made and lost so many friends
with the same or similar conditions
throughout his treatment process he
witnessed children just like him die
before they saw their teenage in adult
years he witnessed their families
witness this he experienced the
traumatic uncertainty of not knowing for
sure if he would be next
when it came to deciding what he wanted
to do with the rest of his life it was
obvious he wanted to prevent or at least
minimize and better manage as many cases
of cancer as possible
and so he studied biochemistry
engineering science and pharmacology
seeking the intersections of genome
sequencing ai and machine learning and
their possible applications towards
various medical treatments
throughout the process the flame of his
motivation remained lit by the hellish
experience of his childhood
in the year 2041 at age 28 nova founded
a biotechnology company that worked to
develop powerful machine learning
technologies that could detect manage
and fight genetic disorders at an
immensely accurate level
10 years later in 2051 using his
technologies nova discovered and
formulated a revolutionary line of drug
treatments that genetically engineered
cells to fight off disorders and
conditions like cancer
nova would become responsible and be
credited with being the first person to
create a versatile cure for various
forms of cancer
over the following years he would go on
to save the lives of millions of people
across the globe and noble would go down
in history as one of the most important
and positively impactful people to ever
cross humanity
in the year 2061 several years later a
boy named draven was born at three years
old draven was diagnosed with an
astrocytoma
brain cancer
prior to nova's early detection
technology and non-invasive drug
treatment draven would not have survived
past early childhood
but because of nova's work draven's life
was saved
by age five he was completely cured and
draven would go on to live a healthy
life
however as an adult he would soon become
a sort of cancer himself
after climbing the ranks of one of the
world's largest militaries draven became
one of the most ruthless and powerful
military generals the world had seen
since the 20th century if not ever
in 2111 in a relatively brief but stark
outbreak of war draven was solely
responsible for unduly executing a
nuclear attack on a major enemy city in
a panic the opposition reciprocated in a
near instant tens of millions of lives
were lost because of draven over the
days weeks and months following the
initial explosion more lives continued
to be lost from critical injuries and
radiation exposure
for every life nova saved including
dravens a multiple of lives were now
lost because of draven's
because of novas
following the existential horrors of the
event all global powers surrendered and
agreed to settle
the world mourned its own
self-destruction and draven would become
known as one of the most evil negatively
impactful individuals to ever cross
humanity
several months later he was assassinated
on the long list of those directly
affected by the nuclear attack was a
young 14 year old girl named alexandra
living far enough away from the nuclear
detonation and thermal pulse alexandra
survived but being much older her father
and mother who suffered sufficient
radiation exposure passed away in the
weeks following the attack
following this alexandra's view of
humanity's future understandably soaked
in cynicism within the debris of the
explosion were giant shards of pessimism
and hopelessness
because of the events alexander became
deeply concerned about the fact that she
shared a planetary home with a species
armed with the weaponry technology and
powers of a god while also the ignorance
and temperament of a fallible irrational
animal
and yet there were no other homes to go
to if anyone like draven became angry
again and decided to burn the whole
house down or if someone just
accidentally left the stove on and so
because of draven's actions alexandra
made it her life's mission to ensure
that humanity became a multi-planetary
species as soon as possible
she would go on to study mathematical
physics and quantum mechanics and
pursuit of this mission
the problem she soon realized however
was that given the current conditions of
technology and humanity's understanding
of time and space there was simply no
way to effectively and efficiently get
beyond the moon or mars
what was needed was a new understanding
of the nature of time and space and the
universe itself in order to get out of
the earth's solar system and onto other
earth-like planets
with the memory of that catastrophic
event and the loss of her parents hung
at the hearth of alexander's drive and
aspiration in the year 2141 after a
cacophony of failures and rejections and
hardships
she did it she discovered what would
become established as the theory of
everything
with this theory alexandria revealed and
explained an oversight of the theory of
general relativity that for the first
time now allowed for an integration of
quantum mechanics
and the possibility of space travel
faster than the speed of light
with this alexander had found the key to
the prison that was earth's solar system
and she would become that rare kind of
genius who only comes once in a century
if that
over the following many years humanity
would explore and touch realms of the
universe that had only seen through
telescopes and dreamed of in science
fiction stories new planets were
discovered new homes were constructed
new lives and futures were established
by 2281 humanity was a multi-planetary
species with bases communities nations
and social political systems forming and
growing on planets all around the milky
way
in the year 2991 a massive asteroid
several hundred miles wide in diameter
was suddenly knocked in the direction of
earth in an effort to alter its course
humanity shot nuclear devices at it
this effort minimized the space object's
size but a giant several mile wide
fragment still remained on course for
earth now further accelerated by the
explosion
this massive asteroid fragment would
collide with earth's surface and in an
instant destroy anything and anyone
within hundreds of square miles of it
this would ultimately cause an
alteration in all of earth's climate as
well as the destruction of most of
earth's technological systems the
remaining portion of the human race
still on earth either left to other
planets before impact or got sent back
to the ages of their ancient ancestors
if humanity was not already elsewhere it
would have been sent back collectively
to some form of the starting line of
history
because of alexandra's work however
humanity continued on
for every life draven had ended a
compounding multiple of lives were now
saved because of alexandra's in a weird
way because of draven's
[Music]
several years later in the year 2301
while on a standard voyager mission a
medium-sized crew of explorers landed on
a newly mapped earth-like planet they
were set to begin development on
while on the planet they encountered
something no explorer had encountered
before
in the middle of a patchy field of grass
and sand stood a massive pure black
obelisk it had perfect edges and angles
and was clearly placed there on purpose
hesitantly the voyager crew approached
as they did they noticed symbols
displayed on the face of it
as they got closer the symbols appeared
to change by the time they reached up to
it the symbols had been translated into
the following
[Music]
greetings we hope this message finds you
well we have known of you for quite some
time
some of you have known of us
we see you have finally left home
congratulations what you have now gained
in freedom and power though you have
lost in innocence
you are now playing in the workplace of
the universe not the sandbox of earth
we have watched you plan your sandbox
with imaginary friends that you called
gods and now we have watched you grow up
just enough to believe you yourself are
them but let us assure you there are no
imaginary friends out here and no gods
believe themselves to be one
you still seem to believe you know what
is good and what is bad you continue to
think good and bad things happen to you
for you or because of you a lingering
sign of your youthful belief in a
god-like intelligence that cares about
you or a god-like intelligence that you
possess
you see an event and all you see is the
event that happened but everything that
has happened and everything that will
happen has already happened all
connected everywhere all at once things
do not happen to you for you or because
of you for good or bad reasons they
happen around and through you for
reasons that are only about you when you
realize you are not actually you
you believe that you are separate from
everything because you define and
separate things but it is you who does
this not reality
so it goes with all species who still
think they are the only child of the
universe
everything is about them
consider this a warm congratulations and
a grave warning
you've been lucky to get this far but
know that luck is just chaos that has
worked in favor of your survival up
until this point
the only gods out here are the odds
see now that the most important
technology you will need will not be
found in the machines you build but the
truths and wisdoms you realize
your greatest threats are certainty and
self-deception your greatest weapons are
humility and thoughtfulness
know that we are watching and we will
like we did with most of those before
you be forced to imprison your entire
species if you show us you are not ready
it is far too risky out here for
ignorance and ego
but if you show us that you are ready we
will welcome you in and you will become
one of us
you will become reality
sincerest and best of wishes
the leader of the voyager group stared
blankly at the obelisk with the gesture
of his arm in hand he ordered his crew
to assemble and aim their weapons toward
it then the commander paused while his
crew
awaited his order
this video was sponsored by babel the
human mind understands the world through
language it is how we categorize make
sense of and express reality and
something extremely interesting is how
understanding different languages can
literally change your understanding of
the world in general what would life
look like for you if you understood
another language perhaps one you've
always wanted to learn but have never
had the time to
babel makes learning new languages easy
efficient and effective with courses on
a wide variety of different languages
with multiple ways to learn whether
through games podcasts videos live
classes with teachers or short
interactive lessons babel provides a
versatile enjoyable way to learn a new
language that actually sticks
not only that but babel's lessons are
created by real language teachers from
around the world and the lessons focus
on preparing you for situations that you
will actually encounter in the real
world like perhaps how to properly order
a couple of coffees from a cafe in a
french-speaking country
perhaps you want to travel to some new
country soon and want to be able to
interact with locals properly and get
the full experience the ability to
engage in a foreign country's local
language creates a completely different
experience that makes it even more
profound or perhaps you want to learn a
new language for personal and
professional reasons like interest in
particular cultures social networks or
businesses or perhaps you want to expand
your cognitive capabilities and further
your understanding of the mind and the
way you can think about this reality
whatever your reasons are babel is a
fantastic way to start and or continue
your journey toward learning new
languages use the link in the
description below and receive up to 65
off your subscription today
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
you